So my name is Vanessa Foxo Lockin. Um,
but I write under the pen name Sam Blake.
Um, and that's with a very good reason
that it's, Natalia is just discovered, oh,
Lochlan is quite hard name to pronounce.
Um,
and obviously it's a very long name and
to fit it onto the cover of a book would
be a bit of a challenge.
Um,
so when I started writing my agent and
I sat down and we had a little think
about it, um, we wanted to work at a
name that would work internationally. Um,
so now I'm Sam Blake, but I'm here
today as both with both hats on.
I'm here as Vanessa and I'm here a sound
like, um, because I started writing,
I'm originally in 1999.
Um,
I don't know how many of you guys maybe
have always felt like maybe you wanted
to write a book.
I think a lot of people do.
And I was one of those people
and I really had that sort of,
always had that feeling since I was quite
small load. Really. I'd write, I read,
I read huge amount. And, um, I sat down,
my husband won't say literally went
sailing across the Atlantic in 1999 for
eight weeks, and I was at
home and my own, um, long,
dark winter evenings cause
it was November. And, um,
I had an idea for a book and I
sat down and started writing yet,
and this is back a long time ago
before I could even use a computer.
So I was writing it out longhand.
Um,
and I've just started really working in
a job where I was starting to learn to
use a computer. It makes me sound
like a total dinosaur. I know,
and I were in here and Google
of all places. Um, but uh,
started writing long hands.
It was going into the office,
the evenings on the weekends
to write it up. And, um,
it was a book called the poison tree.
Um, and it features a detective. Um,
I'm quite lucky that my husband
and fat works the Guardian,
so I have an access into sort of
the police side of things, um,
and how that whole world works.
And, um, I had this idea,
so I literally just started writing and
obviously thought cause you do when it's
your first book and I've actually all
your books that it was amazing because you
just, you'll, I think,
I think one of the key things about
writing is that you need to be optimistic
and you need to be positive.
Um,
and you have to believe in your book
because if you don't believe in your book,
who else is going to believe in it. Um,
and so obviously thought it was fantastic,
finished it and sent it out.
Made the first absolute cardinal
error when it comes to writing a book.
Literally put the last full stop
down and then started sending it out.
And I sent it everywhere.
I sent it to agents and publishers all
over the world and it was rejected by
everybody all over the world. Um, and I,
but I didn't, it didn't really put me off.
I kept going.
Um,
I had an idea for a second book and so
while it was out there being rejected, um,
I kept going, okay. Writing,
I'm Stephen King talks about in his book
on writing about his rejection because
rejection is one of those things
that happens in writing. Um,
it happens a lot in life obviously, but
it particularly happens in writing. Um,
and Steve Martin King talks about
putting all his rejection slips on a nail
above his desk in his book. I didn't
click keep mine, I didn't collect them.
I didn't want to keep that
negative energy in one place. Um,
so I have them scattered all around the
house and I remember doing a workshop a
few years later and somebody
held up a slip at the firm.
One of the Irish publishing has,
I've got one of those,
just one of those add to the collection.
Um, but I kept going, kept writing. Um,
and I suppose one of the things I knew I
needed to do was improve and get better
and learn the techniques of
fiction writing, which are really,
really important.
Um,
I don't think I really knew that there
were techniques when I started writing.
Um, I knew we all learn English in school.
I did a degree in history. You know,
I've written creatively for
school essays and my a levels,
I think my a level essay was
about bees. Um, and so, you know,
you think you can do it and you
read, obviously everybody reads. Um,
so you keep on going.
But I didn't really realize that actually
there were things that will actually
make the fiction better.
And I did a workshop down in dingle
with a lady called Judy Parsons.
And that workshop really helped me hugely
because it really proved to me that I
could write and people, you know,
my peers and other writers. So yeah,
actually you do know what you're doing.
Um,
but it also showed me what I didn't know
and how much I needed to improve and
how much I needed to learn.
Um,
and that's really how inkwell came about
and probably how I got to where I am
now. Um, so I set up, I
wanted to do workshops,
I wanted to do on, to do more workshops.
The weekend the Judy Parsons, as I say,
was down in dingle. And to get there I
had to fly. My parents are from the UK.
I had two small children, then I had to
do, you know, frozen stuff in the fridge.
I had still the notes,
the whole lot.
So it was a major operation getting
away and that really wasn't an option.
And with my husband working shifts,
I couldn't get out to an evening class.
So I was looking at this problem, you
know, I need you to learn how to write.
Could 20 classes, what would I
do? I decided I'd start my own.
So I got in touch with a friend of
mine who's a writer and said, look,
I've had this idea,
you know,
there must be other people out there
that want to do one day intensive fiction
writing workshops. And um, she put
me in touch with some authors. Um,
and cause I was working in
event management at the time.
I was able to sort of bring all those
skills into play and I set up something
called Inkwell, which started off
literally as one day workshops. Um,
and my original plan was to do workshops
on a Saturday because that's when
you're free and almost people
are free and uh, all day.
And they would just be once a month and
they would be just once a month during
the winter because my kids are off during
summer. And obviously, and analogy,
we have very long school holidays. So
I wanted to make sure these, I mean,
these workshops were absolutely,
completely geared to me that will gear to
me learning how to, to write better. Um,
and it turned out once I got them up and
running and I found a hotel and I got
my, my methods sorted out. Um,
because I think it's really important
when you are learning anything and when
you're doing that type, you're
in that type of environment, um,
that you bond with the
person who is speaking.
So I always made sure that I had
two speakers at every workshop. Um,
because if you don't bond with one of
those people, it can ruin the day for you.
And so for me, it's very
important to get that mix. So I,
I got my mix working and it turned out
that I wasn't the only person in this
situation, but actually an awful lot of
other people wanted to do the same thing.
Um, and inkwell became hugely
successful. I bought a huge network.
I had people coming from
Switzerland and India.
I had people coming from the UK
obviously cause it's nice and close, um,
to come to these workshops.
Um,
I used always use bestselling authors
because I'm a great believer that,
you know, you don't, you don't lick it off
of stone. If you get to be best seller,
there's a good reason for it. Um, and so
that's really how inkwell started. Um,
and all the while I was
doing the workshops,
obviously I was learning
how to write that in myself.
I think I've probably sat through more
workshops and most people living because
I've been to the mall and I sit
in the back taking notes. Um,
I kept going and then I discovered
that the writing dot I eat domain was
available. And um, I
thought this is great.
I have this newsletter that I was
sending out to my inquiry people,
main core writers,
and in each newsletter that went out,
I talk about competitions and festivals
and different things that are happening
and what was going on in the writing
world. And every single time I sent it,
literally I press send somebody,
get it, and they go, oh,
did you know about this one?
Did you know about this?
I'd literally get three or four
emails straight back saying, well,
did you know about these? And
I didn't. And I thought, well,
if I'm the person who's supposed to be
trying to coordinate this information and
I don't know what's going on,
then how's anybody else out in the
country know what's going on? Um,
and there was really,
at that point,
there was no central point for
literary information in Ireland.
Even though we are this amazing, literally
nation, we've got Mann Booker winners.
We've got Nobel laureates where a
fantastic story telling nation. Um,
but the wasn't that central point.
So I've discovered the writing dot age
and was available and literally put ink
on newsletter into a website and created
writing dot. A um, it's still going.
It's an online magazine.
We update daily with information.
It's got features in it. It's got, um,
competitions. Just everything really,
me as an aspiring writer wanted
to learn and wants to know about,
has gone into writing. Dot.
Hey you now. Um, and I,
I love meeting writers and then
saying, you know, I read writing a tie.
It still amazes me. Um, maze may amaze me.
We don't know. Ryan told me that he was,
he goes there every morning and his wife
has to tell them to get off it. That's,
that's real reward. Um, so while
all these things are going on, um,
one of the things that was happening
with inkwell was that obviously the
recession hit island,
um,
and literally the bottom fell
out of my business overnight.
So the workshop side of the
business completely collapsed. Um,
there were quite a high end. They
weren't cheap. And, um, you know,
it was one of those moments for anybody
who's worked in a small business will
know that you,
you're,
there are moments when I think in
venture capitalism they call it pivoting,
but it's that moment where you go,
it's not working. We need to think,
rethink this.
And so one of the things that happened
literally that night when I realized
there was no more business,
um,
was that I looked at all the
things I'd been doing. Um,
and the works or something,
giving him the things that we're
really working in the company. Um,
and one of the things that was working
was the scouting side of bit. Um,
I had built lots of
relationships with publishers,
lots of relationships with the editors.
Um,
and all the way along the line I was
meeting new authors and we had new
manuscripts and I was really
enjoying reading them,
but I also discovered the most quite
good at spotting the successful ones.
And so I was sending them
out to the publishers and
they were getting published.
I will send them out to agents
and they were getting picked up.
And so basically I formalized
that side of the business.
I could see that's where we needed to
go. So, um, I became literally scout.
I formalized the arrangements with various
agents that I work with in the UK. Um,
I bought on board a whole
load of different authors
from different genres, um,
who were able to give people,
readers reports.
One of the things that happened to me
through this process was that I'd met an
editor and um,
she quite liked like the work that I was,
the book that I was writing all the time
and it was probably a book number three
at that stage. And um, I, she'd given,
she sent it out to her readers and those
readers had given me feedback on my
work and that there was enormously useful.
Um,
one of the problems of being a writer,
it's very easy as a scout to read
somebody's work and be able to see exactly
what you need to do with it. There
was an editor at that, I say easy.
It isn't easy, but you know, you're,
you can see what needs fixing with
your own work. You can't see it at all.
You can't see it. It's so bizarre.
I think it's because when you write,
you have the images in your head and my
job is to take the images from my head
and turn them into words and the page,
they were forming images in your head.
But because I can see the picture,
I might have forgotten to tell you that,
you know, Fred blogs that just walked in
the back door, then you've got one leg,
cause I know he's only got one leg,
but if I haven't put it on the page,
you can't see it. So that from a writer's
perspective, um, is a tricky one.
Um, so raw writers need is people to
help is to people to read their work.
And so I have a lot of authors now who
worked for me who do what we call readers
reports.
So they will read a finished book and
they will look at the plot development and
the character development,
all of those important things and help
an author move it along and bring up to
the next level. Um, so that's sort of the,
how the publishing consultancy side
grew literally as a result of the,
of the bottom falling out of the
business. Um, and is now very successful.
Um, and really the literary
scouting side is what brought me on.
So while I'm building the businesses, um,
and doing these various bits and pieces,
I kept writing. Um, and I think it's
absolutely essential for people. Um,
or for everybody. I mean, the literal,
the best advice I was ever given was just
keep writing. Um, signing Beckett said,
you know, fail, fail better,
just keep on failing. And that's,
and I think that's what it's all about.
It's that it's,
it's improving and improving,
improving.
Malcolm Gladwell talks about 10,000 hours,
you know,
that you need to hit that 10,000 hours
in order to reach the tipping point. Um,
and that is so true and it's
true in writing as much as
it is in everything else.
Um, so I kept going, I was
busy writing away and I,
one morning I had coffee or something,
coffee with one of the agents I
work with in London and um, he just,
we found a book,
I'd found a book,
sent it to him and he sold it
for a lot of money. And, um,
he was very successful agent and we
were sitting down having a little cup of
coffee and common garden and I had a book
with me on the counter and was put by
a friend of mine.
Could Alex Barclay,
it was proof copy of one of
her books and he saw, you know,
you're reading Alex
Barky. I said, well, yeah,
she's been really influential on my
writing because in fact this is a trade
secret.
I completely stolen.
I'm Alex [inaudible] system of plotting
and planning because she hasn't worked
out and I literally have taken,
she taught me how to do it and like that's
what I use. So, um, he said, oh, you know,
you're, you're, you're eating
her. And I said, yeah, very
inflection. And he went, Oh,
do you? Right. And somewhere
in the midst of things,
one of the things I think
certainly for me, um,
and probably for the people that wear
lots of different hats and different
businesses is that it's quite difficult
field to understand what you do. Um,
so sometimes I'm industry consultants,
sometimes I'm a website managing person,
sometimes I'm an author and I'm
also the chair of Irish pen and I'm,
I do lots of different things.
And this Simon Cohen,
who is my agent now hadn't grasped
obviously the bit, the most important bit,
which was the writing. So he said to me,
what you're working on? And I said, well,
I'm working on this book. It's called, uh,
it wasn't called the, the little bones,
then it's called the dressmaker. And, um,
it's about the bones were
baby turning up in the,
of her wedding dress and the detector
who has to find out what happens.
And he went, oh, I'd like to see
that. And I had one of those moments,
the total paralysis, because this
is this massive agent in London.
He's works for a huge company. There
are Hollywood talent agency. And, um,
he wants to see my writing, which
sounds amazing, brilliant opportunity.
But then as a scout,
I'm thinking if I sent him my
work and he absolutely hates it,
I completely shot myself in the
foot. I mean, it's, you know,
what happens if it's a
disaster? It's like, okay, yes,
I can find on people's advice.
You can't write myself a,
but I'm under this illusion
that perhaps I can.
So I had one of those moments
of like, oh my God, literally.
But fortunately there was, we had a happy
ending. Um, because when you did like it,
I read it, the book right
the way through the next day.
And I'm getting emails saying,
you know, when you're sending it,
when you're sending it. And then she did
send it and thank God he did like it.
And even better, he was able to
sell it, which is also a bonus.
So the first book came out in, I've now
forgotten the year 2016 I think, um,
little bones.
Um,
and that is the story of the baby's
bones in the head with a hammer wedding
dress. Um, and that story
really came about because I'm,
Stephen came towards him,
his book on writing,
which for anybody who is interested
in writing and, um, you know,
wants to go that way.
It's absolutely the Bible.
It is the best book possibly ever
written on writing. It's fantastic.
And every single published author I
know has it on their shelf. Um, so in,
in that book he talks about great story
being the collision of two unrelated
ideas,
how he talks about how with books,
how to completely separate ideas came
together and creates the new idea created
story. Um, and that's really what
happened to me with little bones.
I'd seen an rt documentary
years ago, um, about, um,
a serving girl or girl who,
who I thought was a serving girl has
turned out she works in a rubber factory.
And I went to go do the investigation
who had left Ireland in the 1930s and
she'd gone to the UK because she was
pregnant and she wants to hide the
pregnancy.
And um,
she found herself we're living in the
landlady's house or working in a factory
and you know,
unable to cope the situation.
And what happened to her was that she
actually had the baby in the middle of the
night in a room that she shared with the
12 year old daughter if her landlady.
Um, and obviously you can
imagine the state she was in. Um,
she went to the bathroom,
sort herself out and when she came back,
the baby wasn't breathing. So she wrapped
the baby up. I now know in a blue dress,
cause I went to find all the,
the court details and she put the baby
into a suitcase and put it in under her
bed and went back to Ireland a Christmas.
It was just before Christmas,
went back to Ireland or
Christmas to talk to her priest.
And in that time that she was away,
the baby's body was discovered and
she was one of the last people to be
convicted of infanticide in the UK.
And for some reason this just,
I call them light bulb
moments when you are,
when you see something or you
hear something or you know,
you can be as TESCO's looking at some
of these basket or overhear something on
the train and you get this little light
bulb moment thinking that's really
interesting and that this
thing stuck with me, the baby,
the suitcase under the bed. And then
I was driving back from the airports.
Then a few 10 years later,
I think possibly,
and I was put on the radio and
Artie has documentary about, um,
a chap who had written a play
called the country, a dressmaker.
And his play was one of the, one of the
places saved the Abbey Theater from, from,
um, total disaster. And he
had died. He was a very,
very successful playwright, but he
died destitute, um, in an apartment,
a little room up in cable
street in Dublin. Um,
and what he'd done is he'd left all his
plays in a suitcase on his bed and there
was a suitcase as the
connection in my mind. Um,
and this is a few years ago now when I
started working on it before they built
the m 50, and they were, I think,
32 sets of traffic lights
between my house in the airport.
So it was a long drive. And on that
long drive, by the time I got home,
I had been thinking about dresses,
had been thinking about dressmakers,
been thinking about unplanned pregnancies,
and I'd come up with the idea that
perhaps, um, the girl, Mable, Agnes Regan,
I think her name was in, uh, in England.
The one thing she wanted was
that was a wedding dress.
And so by the time I arrived home,
the bones were in the
hem of the wedding dress.
Now I didn't know until I was two
thirds the way through that book,
how they actually got there.
I knew they were in there,
had a really clear impression of it.
I had the people starting to map sketch,
sketch out in my head. Um, but I didn't
really know how they got there at all.
And it wasn't until I started writing a
piece of witness testimony in the book,
um, that I realized and I remember
emailing it's Barkley Pet Dallas market,
I know why the bones are in the
wedding dress. And she's like, yes.
And it's funny when you write crime
you have to plot to a certain extent,
you have to plan to a certain extent
because of all the things that you know,
plots are quite twisted for any
of you have read no turning back,
which is the most recent sand lake.
Um, it's quite a complex plot.
There's two or three different storylines
going on in there and making sure that
those things dovetail together
and that the right bits,
the left and the right places as part of
that plotting process. Um, and as I say,
I've stolen Alix,
Barclays system of plotting.
So I use this columns across the page
and make my notes in it as I go along.
But often with writing and most
importantly with writing is allowing the
characters to breed on age and allowing
them to speak to you. And when they do,
when they take over the story and when
they start to do things that you don't
necessarily expect that some
stories really, really happening.
And that's what happens in little bones.
And I found out about the bones and in
fact to no turning back the ending of
know Talia bridger lending know no
turning back. There's totally different,
there was a different,
everything was different about it and um,
it doesn't feel quite right. Um,
I'm a great believer that your,
when you write,
you're using your subconscious mind.
And I remember Joseph icon over at an
event I was at was talking about, um,
how the character sort of float in
the ether above your head a bit.
And as a writer you're sort of channeling
them. It's a very strange process.
Um,
but it is a bit like that.
It's like they're all actually
out there that every book,
every character and every book is actually
floating around out there somewhere
and they're just waiting to find the
person to channel through to tell their
story. Um, and so certainly was
finding when you find cat colony,
the detective,
um,
she came to me pretty much fully formed
kickboxing detective and with the
various stories,
you,
your subconscious mind is the thing that
really works and if you're going wrong
or, um, people talk about
writer's block a lot,
I really believe that writer's block
is your subconscious mind putting the
brakes on. Um, and certainly in my
second book, which is got in deep water,
I got stuck writing that about
two thirds of the way through,
even though I had my plot, worked out,
my plans and all the rest of it. And, um,
I realized I had gone wrong.
And then when I went back to fix the
bit that got where I'd gone wrong,
I realized I'd actually gone
wrong earlier than that even.
So there were two twists
in it, the were wrong. Um,
and I think it's understanding
that is really important.
So for anybody who is writing, um,
and does find that they get stuck, um,
there's usually a very good reason for it.
As I was coming in here
on the dark this morning,
I've just started a new book and it's
about Sentara stuff happening in London
and I've just realized that the,
um,
the reason that's not working
as us as something a bit offer,
I haven't been able to
work out what it was.
And I think I've got my chemistry wrong.
So I was texting my daughter on
the train coming in and saying,
do you know anybody who's
good at chemistry? I need to
check on me chemicals. Um,
so that's that. I think that's really,
really important element to understand.
But at one of the key things,
one of the key things with writing
I suppose with anything in life, um,
is to just embrace it,
enjoy it and try and try certainly for
new writers to get to the end of the
manuscript, it's, it's really,
really important to try and write that
first draft right the way through to the
end.
Because very often,
and this is sort of I suppose the
scouts end of things speaking, um,
the first three chapters of the manuscript
on really the first three chapters of
the book. They're not the
first two chapters. The, you,
the reader will necessarily see,
um,
because it takes a while
to get into the story.
And so it can quite often it can be,
especially with a new writer,
it can take a while for
you to get into the store.
And I know certainly little bones, um,
had a whole long prologue. There's a bit,
it's now, there's one
paragraph in the, in the start,
a little bones in the first chapter.
Uh, we're an artist called [inaudible].
He talks about this piece of work that
she's working on and her family and
things like that.
And that was the prologue,
but that was two and a
half thousand words. Um,
but it was something I needed to write
to find my way into the story. Um,
but it wasn't something that you
necessarily all needed to read.
So that has ended up now down as one
paragraph, but it's just very interesting.
One of the absolute crucial
things I suppose to understand
but also to know as a
writer is that it's the reshaping
and the rewriting of the manuscript,
which is the bit that makes it happen.
Um, once you get the story down,
you lay it down, it can be
a bit of a muddle. It can
be a mess, bits cannot work.
Um, but it's really, um, it's that
reshaping, it's the editing. It's the,
the rewriting that is absolutely crucial
to making it into something that people
want to read. So how are we doing
for time in Italia that we were good.
We,
um,
so I suppose one of the
key things as well, um,
in terms of crime writing it's plot.
Um,
but at the same time,
this character,
which is absolutely essential
unless you have good characters,
why would you want to read on? Um, so
plot plot is very, very important. Coming.
Those two unrelated ideas, um, are,
are absolutely essential to try
and bring them together. Um, but,
but story is all about character and you
need to be able to empathize and really
love that character in order to want to
read the story. Because as an author,
I'm asking you not only as part
with your cash to buy my book,
but I'm asking you to part with that sort
of six or seven hours of your time. Um,
and that's an important contract. So in
order to deliver a story and to deliver,
um, something that makes you want
to keep turning those pages, um,
character is absolutely vital.
And understanding your characters and
knowing them as really, really important.
Um, and characters change, they develop,
they can develop while
you're writing the book. Um,
I was blessed with cat colony
because she came fully formed.
And one of the things about
writing theories is that it's,
when you go back to the next story,
it's a bit like going to meet your friends
in the pub because you know them so
well, you know what they're going to say
and sort of the, the cost if you like,
is already there. So it's a bit
like writing a Sitcom, isn't it,
where you know everybody already and then
you just have to apply the story. Um,
so writing a series is fantastic from
a writer's point of view because you
couldn't really get into the sort of
the plotting end of things. And I think,
I'm hoping I get better with each book
and I think no turning back is probably
one of the best so far. Um, but
literally book I've just written, um,
and hopefully will be coming out towards
the end of this year or early next year.
Um, it's a whole new cast
as a standalone. And, um,
so that meant a whole new set of
characters, a whole new story. Um,
it's about two women who meet our plane,
um,
and discover that they have men in their
lives who aren't doing everything they
should for them, um, and that they
can help each other out a bit, um,
to right the wrongs. Um, and that's
a whole new, whole new set of people.
Um, and again, it's, it's, it's developing
those people. It's getting to know them.
It's knowing their background
and names where they come from,
all of the things that make you, you. Um,
and I think for anybody who's writing,
I always think one of those,
you know,
when you meet somebody for the first
time and you form where we talk about
psychologists,
so it's about where do you form an
opinion in the first 30 seconds of meeting
somebody, what does it do you
see? You maybe see the, hey,
you see what color jumper they're wearing.
You might make assumptions
about them from their footwear,
Sherlock Holmes fanatic, but he was
always looking at people's shoes. Um,
and they're the impressions
that you form with character.
So it's very important when
certainly for me as a writer, um,
to get a feel for those characters,
to know what they look like.
I use storyboards and, um, I go around
the Internet and I go to magazines.
I find pictures of the characters,
the people who look like the
people who are in my head. Um,
and they can come from all
sorts of strange places.
The sample poor guy from New
York who's on Tinder and I not,
not where I used to enter subsea.
I'm happily married,
but I'm who I found on the search who
is the spirit of one of my characters in
the next book.
So he's up there too,
so they can come from
anywhere and they're just,
there's just like a private
reference point for me. Um,
and I find that really
useful. Particular, I suppose,
cause I'm busy because I'm working and
I'm doing the various bits and pieces
with the, um, running quell and
helping you rice all the time. Um,
and moving around a lot. Um, I don't, I,
I don't get to write every single day.
I mean biters talk about writing every
day and that that's really important,
but it's not always feasible.
Um,
I try and write as often as I can
and try and stay in the story,
but I find storyboards are really
useful for me because I've got a visual
representation of who everybody is and I
stick that I have make up a big a three
one. And it's partly as procrastination
because I think as an author,
when you start off with a story and you've
got this big blank thing in front of
you,
you spend a lot of time not actually
writing anything and just knowing that you
should be doing something.
But anyway,
I spent a lot of time at historicals
and I put them on my desk and that means
that those characters are
calling out to me. So whenever,
wherever else I'm doing that,
those people are there looking
at me and I'm literally saying,
come tell my story. Um, and I really,
really, I find those that are really,
really useful part of the process.
Um, so we've, where we go to questions
perspective or an unpublished writer,
everything looks really,
really bad. Uh, so the first question is
like, how do you actually stop writing?
Because every time you're finished
vizio draft it Kinda looks good,
but then you read a book,
like you read a really good book and
you look at your draft and it's awful.
You start writing again, it never stops.
You sent it to an editor at Detroit,
gives you back the comments you've
worked on Samhsa trust looks good,
but then you look again at it in
a month's time. It's awful again.
And the second question is,
uh,
given first, right and like
everyone a thrust frightened
is soft. It's, it's fine.
Like y'all need to
improve and work on what,
what do you do with your first
trust to just touch them off to you?
Like is there any reason to self
publish those? Is there any uh,
reason to send them to magazines
or whatever? Like what do you do?
Visit first draft that you know, there
are like in your head like, so sorry,
your children, you've walked
in down force such a long time.
What do we do with them?
How do you give them up?
I think the first thing is to
try and work on your book, um,
until you can't see anything else wrong
with that. So you got to a point, yes,
because that is the whole point.
The whole process is that every time you
go back and you see something else you
want to fix, so keep working on it.
And it might be a long process. I mean,
I said I started writing in 1999.
Um,
it took me 15 years now to actually get
a deal. Now it was five bucks later. Um,
but um, it was a long time. Um,
and the best advice I was ever given
was just keep writing and you only get
better.
Going back to Malcolm Gladwell,
you only get better through writing and
you only find your voice through writing.
Writing,
I'm also publishing is always looking
for what's called voice unique voice. Um,
we don't need another J K Rowling. It
doesn't mean we don't need another swab.
We'd love to have another deck here
early and a lot of the Stephen King but
didn't, I mean we've already got
one so we don't need another one.
So finding your voice and your unique
voice is really important and you only do
that literally through putting words
on the page. Um, so in terms of drafts,
the rewriting is vital.
That polishing process is vital.
I think you have to just keep on going
until you cannot see anything else that
needs to be changed.
When you get to the point where you just
don't know what else you can do to it
to make it better. And that can be a long,
long time. It could be 10 drafts later.
I mean I'm, I'm on what book
published book for now. I'm
just, I've just finished,
I'm onto the next one.
I've written probably four or
five complete books before that.
So I'm looking at having written nine
books of 100,000 words each and I still on
the book I have to sent in its draft six.
So it's,
so that drafting process is
vital all the way through. Um,
so when you get to the point
where you can't say anymore,
you don't know what else to do to it,
then then the opportunity then as an
option to get professional help and see if
you can get somebody like an editor
to read it and try and improve it.
If you get to the point then where you
think it's, it's done, it's ready to go,
it's at that point,
then send it out.
Absolute is publishers to agents
and see how you get on with it.
The thing with self publishing,
self publishing is wonderful
because you can actually find,
you can get out there, you can
get books out there, those drafts.
At the end of the day,
there's an awful lot of writers in the
world and there are only so many books
that can be published.
Um,
and so there's always going to be more
writers than there are people with the
capacity to publish.
So I think self publishing is amazing.
I know some people who have been
incredibly successful at it.
The key is that you need
to see it as a job, um,
and approach it very professionally and
understand that the marketing and the
editing and the cover needs to be to
professional standards because you're
competing with, you know, published
books out there on the shelf.
So it's all about learning that whole
process. Um, so self publishing is great.
Yes,
absolutely.
If you send it out and you can't land
an agent and you can't land a publishing
deal with it necessarily,
absolutely self published,
I sell probably one of my books,
I wrote a romance and in Romancey
there wasn't really crime,
sort of dark romancey thing
called true colors. And um,
I'd had that had another agent long,
long time ago and she sent it out and
I got what we call rave rejections.
Self published the wall, everybody, cause
I'm ready for rejections where somebody,
they love your book. Um, but nobody
can find a place fresh or they can't,
they're not actually quite in a position
to buy it even though they love it. And,
um, I felt that that was a great book and
I decided and I'll get out there and to
see, you know, absolutely self
publish it too. Um, so there's,
and there's different these days,
there are different routes for writers,
so you can be a hybrid, right? You can
do both. Um, so absolutely send it out,
work on it till you can not see any more
things that can be improved then get
professional help,
then send it out.
If it's still not jelling
with that particular book,
then absolutely look
at self publishing it.
The key was self publishing is
that again, as I say, you're,
you're competing with the
publish books that are out there.
So it needs to be of the highest possible
standard that you can get it. Um,
and you can't take back negative reviews.
You know,
if it goes out on Amazon and you know,
there's,
we haven't had a proof read and
there's masters of Typos in it,
somebody's going to tell you
and you can't change that.
So it's really important to be as
professional as you can about it. Um,
but it's an exciting world.
I think as,
as one of the most exciting things about
writing is the fact that, you know,
you can do anything, you don't know
where it's going to take you. Um,
publishing's always looking for something
original that's looking for a new
voice. It's looking for a new concept. Um,
they're looking for authors,
Debbie authors that they can build,
they can put marketing behind. Um,
and you know, to break you out.
So they're looking at was for
what's called a breakout book,
which is a big story if you can,
if you can do that.
And sometimes I think it's important
for people to understand it.
Sometimes it isn't your first book
that gets published quite often.
Your first book is that learning
ground. You know, it's, you
know, if we started, um,
the back to the 10,000 hours,
I'm,
a friend of mine has a great analogy
when she talks about playing football and
how you guys all learned, we all learned
football in school and, you know,
people go out, you know, kids go out and
they kick a ball around on the green,
outside the house, put the
jumpers down for goalposts. Um,
but none of those people expect to go
and play out play for AC Milan and the
next morning. You know, and I think
one of the things with writing,
certainly all the things I did
with that first book way back when,
was that when you write,
you think it's going to be the book,
it's fantastic and it's amazing and that
you're going to be out there playing
for AC Milan.
But it's that learning process that
takes time and you're doing all the right
things if you're keeping redrafting and
you're doing absolutely all the right
things. So just have to keep on going.
Just keep writing the best advice.
I have a quick question about
your writing process. Um,
would you usually write every day for
force yourself to write everyday or would
you perhaps wait for when you're inspired
and would you also wrote in the right
order or would you maybe write
a random dialogue for example?
I think that's a really good
question actually because I'm,
I'm a really organized person and I
need to write in a linear fashion.
So I have to start at the beginning
of the book. And end at the end. Um,
other friends of mine don't
write that at that at all.
I don't know how they do rich,
but they are obviously their minds
work in a completely different way.
And they would write like a scene.
Like if they suddenly want
to write a fight scene,
they'd write that from the end and then
something else from the beginning and
then they put it all together. Um, I,
I use tool called scrivener and quite a
lot of authors use scrubbing up and to
collect the bits together.
I actually just use it for my research
so that I can put stuff into files and
then find them again. Um, and um,
so if you do write in
that out of order way,
then that can be a really useful tool.
Um,
personally I write in a very
linear fashion, um, and I
do try and write every day,
but it doesn't always
happen. Um, I think about,
I think you think about your book all
the time when you're working on it. So,
like I was saying, coming out in
the dark, I wasn't actually writing,
but I was doing some,
I was plotting in my head,
I was thinking trying to work out
where I was going with the story. Um,
and I think as a writer it's always
there with you and it needs to be always
there with you. I remember
somebody emailed me once
and, um, long, long time ago,
and she said, Oh yeah, I'm going on
holiday so I'm going to take, you know,
I won't be taking the book.
I won't be able to work on that because
I'm going on holiday. And I thought, well,
if you're a writer,
you write all the time.
I drive my family marriage cause I write
on holiday and I, it's my thing. I love,
it's the thing I love to do most.
And um, so I, yeah, so I sit there,
I get up at six o'clock in the morning
when I'm on holiday and that to me it's a
couple of hours typing away
as the thing to do. Um, yeah.
So I try and write everyday. If
I'm not writing every day, I um,
I'm thinking about it when you're
under deadline is different and should,
one of the key,
I suppose one of the crucial things is
that when you don't have a contract,
when you're an unpublished
writer as I was,
you have the luxury of time and it's
really difficult to recognize that because
you're desperate to get published
in a desperate to get the deal.
But you have the absolute luxury of time
you can spend as long as it takes and
make that book the best that it can be.
If it's not that book,
it might be the next book or the
next book, the next book, but that,
that you've got all the time
in the world to do that.
When you get under contract and you
something get deadlines and you suddenly
find that actually your,
your you've written book won.
Cause that was fine that you have that
written and then all of a sudden you've
got to write book too.
Um,
and then you've got to come up with an
idea for book three and then you might be
launching. What happened to me
was I was launching book too,
and trying to finish book
three at the same time. Um,
and suddenly you might have to write,
I had to write 30,000 words in nine days,
wants to get book three finishers as
partly what they end and had to be
completely rewritten. But, um, you,
you just, it's a whole different world.
So I think enjoy that time. And um, yeah,
so when I'm under contract and when,
when you're an entrepreneur,
you're under deadline.
It's much more every day it's like
this is the thing I've got to do. Um,
and it actually,
it helps if you're in the zone and you
can stay and it's much more than trying
to write bits and pieces,
but you do train yourself.
I think you train yourself to write,
to suit your lifestyle.
So,
um,
I wrote at least 2000 words and one of
the books on plane to Frankfurt Book Fair,
um, leaves here at what, seven
o'clock in the morning. So it was,
it was an early start. And, um, you know,
I've written on trains, I write and cafes,
I write everywhere and
noise doesn't bother me.
One of the things I do
do is I have a sour,
tend to have a soundtrack for each book.
So Cat Conley is obviously 24 a lot
younger than me. She listens to pop music.
She's, she's 24 year olds. So I have a,
like whatever's in the charts
is her soundtrack at the time.
So I would make a soundtrack for each
book and I plug my earphones in and stick
them in and they,
that helps drown out everything else
that's going on in my head as well as the
noise around me. Um, so that,
it means I can really focus on the book
and when I hear that sound than I know
I'm in the zone for writing. This book
is about a woman who was an ex ballerina,
so it's the Moscow symphony and I'm,
and I'm using that for, for this one,
for the soundtrack,
for this one.
The next book I done all of
that soundtracks going to be,
I know you're just starting it,
so we'll wait and see.
But I find that enormously useful
because it just, it helps. Helps. Yeah.
Look out,
look out the sound at wherever you are,
but also what's going on
in your head. Um, yeah,
so I think in one of the things about
writing is that it's really worth
listening to writers, lots of
different writers because we all do,
we all do the same thing and we
all use bits of the same technique,
but we all have developed
them in our own way.
And there's no right or wrong way to,
right.
So some people write
bits all over the place,
some people write organically and
they don't plot. Some friends of mine,
Monica Mcinerney wrote and her telling
me she about 40,000 words of a book and
in totally the wrong direction,
it was complete a complete like bull
wrong cause you had to literally delete
40,000 that's half a book. Right?
But in that for staff and words,
there were a couple of paragraphs
which are absolutely crucial to the
progression of the plot.
And she wouldn't have found if she
hadn't written the 40,000 words.
So nothing is ever wasted in writing.
You know,
it might be that you write a book
and it never sees the light of day,
but it's not what not wasted because
you've used that time and you'll create,
mine has been working on it. Um, and
you know, it's, it's really, really,
really vital. So, yeah, so
technique listened to writers,
find out how everybody else does it,
find out what works for you,
and then you can, um, you can draw in
and devise your own way of doing things.
Um, that works with your lifestyle. Some
people have little kids and they can't,
you know, they can only write.
I used to, I mean, right, Jim,
my daughter's nap time and my daughter
would only sleep for 20 minutes at a time.
So I think I learned quite early on
to 20 minutes. And when you've got,
when you've only got 20 minutes,
it's amazing what you can do. Um,
you block everything else
out. So, uh, yeah, everybody's
different. But yeah. Find,
find the way that works for you.
You mentioned the luxury of time and
still young in my district for 13 years.
So what's your advice for someone who
just wants to get thing out there but it
doesn't want to be dealing with loads and
loads of details like cover design. Oh,
ESPN this thing,
that thing.
Some other detail as most Googlers.
Just want to get a tech out there.
Dot. Not really interested in making
a whole bunch of cash out of it. Okay.
It's like got a day job.
You want people to read it. Yeah.
Okay. So if you want people to read it,
then you can't, there are lots of
companies who do all that for you,
so you don't have to
worry about any of this.
You just go to one of them and
they will that professional. Um,
I can give you the names as a couple,
two or here in Ireland are very good.
They come back from trade backgrounds
and they understand the business. Um,
but things like, um, yeah,
getting a good cover. Um,
it's crucial because that's how it reads,
recognizes a book. You know yourself,
when you go into a bookshop,
you pick the book up,
depending what the couple of sites
turn over and lead the back to open it,
read those first few paragraphs.
So those things have only really,
really important. Um,
so yeah, if you, if you,
you're at that point where you
don't want to be bothered with it,
the doings of the makings that,
but you've done that,
you've already done
your best and making so,
and I think I would probably just get a
company to one of the companies to come
who do that professionally to do it
and they'll do it properly for you and
they'll, they'll get your
great cover, they'll help you
with a blurb, um, and then,
and then you can still self published.
So you're still doing it yourself. Um,
but do send out to the trade first,
you know,
do get it again and there
just to have a look at it.
I'll get a reader's report done on it.
So you know that what you've got
there is the right bit. Um, and then,
and do look at, think about another
story too. You know, that the,
I suppose that's really important is that
if you are, um, everybody's different.
I mean like maybe you only want to write
one book and that's fantastic because
you have obviously,
um,
and actually getting to the end is a
massive achievement because there are lots
of people who want to write books and not
very many people actually finish them.
Um, but, um, if you are writing and
you finish one book can keep thinking,
think about the second one
because if you do get a contract,
it won't be for one book, it be
for a minimum of two. And um,
you need to have that,
that next idea really should go,
it will make a huge difference.
We'll help you with this awful contract
deadline look. Um, so, um, yes,
I do keep writing, but no, absolutely.
People can help you out and
get it out there for you. Um,
but do you know, get, get.
Yeah,
it's hard when you've spent a lot time
working on things to do starting today.
If you enjoyed that process, start
thinking about the next one, move on.
Hmm.
You usually give really good advice as
to those who are in the beginning of the
process and they really like
the idea about the storyboard.
So how it usually works,
for example,
it's like a detectives in crime movies.
Do this by thinking,
searching, put in together,
all the pieces for it. How,
how you would recommend
to use the storyboard.
Okay. Well I do, I, so I get the pictures
of the people and then the locations.
I spend a lot of time looking. I'm, I'm
uh, cause I'm a detailed person. Um,
I like to be in control of everything
and I'm really into the whole getting
everything right. Um, so I
would go to find the locations.
I try and visit the locations.
If I writing about them.
I try and use places I've been.
So if it's inside of somebodies apartment,
I've been to the apartment and I,
but I do go onto these property websites
and I get people's floor plans. Um,
and I,
you know,
in the interior shops are different
people's houses and I put those into my
storyboard.
So it just means then if I'm writing
about somebody going into the living room,
um,
I don't forget that actually they can,
what they can see out
the window or I forget,
don't forget that the kitchen's off
this particular room as opposed to a
different one. Um, in theory,
when you get to the point where
when you're going to bring,
you have a copy editor looking at your
book and that sort of final editorial
process, they'll notice like if
eight people went into the left,
only four people came out, but,
um, or somebody is pregnant
for nine for 14 months,
I think one of my friends managed. Um,
but, uh, those, those type of details,
I think a great for a story board because
particularly locations because then
you can see where your people are.
Um,
I've got one character who I
think might live on a houseboat.
And so because we're very close to
grand canal dock has spent a lot of time
walking around Grand Canal dock,
getting pictures of houseboats,
trying to find the right layout for the
house, both for the story that I wanted.
And um,
I've got,
so I've got a whole houseboat lay out
on my and pitches of Grand Canal and
different places where they might have
stayed on my storyboard. Yeah. So,
so I just find them really
useful. I mean, in the film,
obviously people plot out the actual story
on storyboards and they use them for,
you know, an animation stuff. You
use them to actually tell the story.
But I just tend to have a static one,
which has like locations and sometimes
the dressmaker had bits of lace on it
from wedding dress and it
had, um, a deck of cards.
I think I had stuck on it and all sorts
of bits of just bits that were just,
I felt we were going to go into
the stories pooling the, I suppose,
the creator place. Yeah.
So by phone renucell
thank you very much. Uh, I
think, uh, that's all for today.
I really appreciate it. It was,
I think, very inspiring story.
And the toe is good when you can talk
to a person who has already a success
Korea and who can also share some
advices and does that give some tips and
tricks and although small exercises
that are quite useful for many people,
thank you so much.
Bye.
Okay.